[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes tout de suite
les titres de ce jeudi 4 juin
depuis mardi les collèges rouvrent peu à
peu sur le territoire après les
professeurs c'était au tour des élèves
de faire leur entrée ce matin
exemple dans un établissement de
chanteloup les vignes où s'est rendu le
président du département des yvelines
même s'il ne s'est pas figé complètement
pendant le confinement le tribunal
judiciaire de versailles a désormais
repris entièrement son activité avec
forcément des adaptations liées au
contexte sanitaire reportage
et puis conséquence d'une période de
deux mois passés à la maison les
consommateurs se tournent davantage vers
les produits de proximité est notamment
la viande locale provenant des yvelines
une tendance observée par les
professionnels du secteur le point pour
commencer sur la situation du
coronavirus dans les yvelines où 497
personnes sont décédées soit une
supplémentaire entre mardi et mercredi
et les dernières données sont à la
baisse - trente et une hospitalisation
en 24 heures 539 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier sur le territoire 35
en réanimation
soit 2 15 ans - en 24 heures depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et 1940 et
une personnes ont été guéries de lakovic
après un passage à l'hôpital c'était
donc la rentrée aujourd'hui pour les
collégiens un retour en classe par
petits groupes et très progressif sur le
territoire yvelinois classées en orange
pour rappel à chanteloup-les-vignes le
collège magellan restés ouverts pendant
le confinement pour les enfants du
personnel soignant a accueilli ce jeudi
ses élèves de 6e et le président du
département des yvelines leur a rendu
visite pour l'occasion sur place manon
varaldo c'est une rentrée particulière
pour les élèves du collège magellan à
chanteloup les vignes dès leur arrivée
désinfection des mains et port du masque
obligatoire
38 élèves de 6e font leur retour dans
cet établissement d'une capacité totale
de 2 199 élèves distance d'un mètre
séparation des tables à la cantine
affiche tout le protocole sanitaire a
été mise en place
le ménage est également accentuée dans
ce collège qui accueillait les enfants
du personnel soignant pendant le
confinement
on ne fonctionne plus comme avant les
enfants n'ont plus de carnet de liaison
ça veut dire qu'il ya plus de punitions
il ya plus d'heures de retenue donc je
vous dis c'est une vraie un vrai rapport
de confiance d'accueil
on essaie aussi de s'adapter davantage
aux élèves dans les classes
onze élèves maximum sauf dans les salles
de sciences avec 15 élèves certains
professeurs continuent le suivi des
élèves à distance mais la plupart des
enseignants sont de retour
il met en place des projets pédagogiques
avec leurs élèves
la fresque qu'ils veulent perdre dans la
cour ou qu'il s'agisse pour vivre a
raconté cette histoire de déconfinement
de faire une chanson avec une artiste
elle les enfants pensent aussi aux
vacances dans ce contexte particulier la
ville proposera des activités
c'est un principe il n'y a pas une
journée on ne propose pas quelque chose
à un groupe de groupe trois groupes
utiliser l'ensemble du territoire et
tout ce qu'il a comme mme équipements
publics comme équipements d'extérieur
troisièmement travailler sur toutes les
tranches d'âge faire de l'éducatif du
culturel du sportif tout mélanger et
faire autant que peu se peut et sait ce
que j'étais en train de valider du de la
mise à distance aussi
un certain nombre de possibilités à
l'extérieur 41 % des élèves ont déclaré
revenir au collège magellan à partir de
lundi un retour en classe très attendu
pour certains d'autant qu'avec le
confinement
les élèves ont dû suivre les cours à la
maison une situation inédite qui a
provoqué plusieurs inégalités et de
nombreuses familles n'ont pas pu en
effet profité de la continuité
pédagogique par manque de moyens
technologiques aux mureaux une
association a tout de même pu fournir
des ordinateurs pour éviter le
décrochage scolaire le reportage de
mélanie potier ben voilà il ya internet
de se connecter avec la boxe machin et
il ya aussi word excel un ordinateur
plutôt attendue du matériel informatique
qui a manqué à joal et ses frères et
soeurs pendant le confinement
jusqu'à présent il travaillait avec un
téléphone portable via beaucoup plus de
devoirs et c'est un peu plus compliqué à
à les expliquer
c'est pas comme à l'école on est des
parents donc c'est pas facile de les
expliquer qu'on les profs le fond c'est
l'enfant qui essaye de comprendre un
ordinateur donné par une association
catholique le rocher oasis des cités
travaillent sur les mureaux depuis 2010
quatre familles sont aujourd'hui équipés
sur la commune l'idée c'était de voilà
on a on a fait un une sorte de
recensement on va dire des différentes
familles avec lesquelles le rocher en
lien et il nous a semblé pertinent de
fournir ces ordinateurs la aux familles
qui a eu des soucis voilà dans laquelle
il y avait plusieurs enfants à faire
travailler des familles avec lesquelles
on avait aussi un lien construit dans le
temps voilà c'est des enfants qui sont
accompagnés par le rocher depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
un don qui s'accompagne d'une formation
informatique joël ne retournera pas à
l'école d'ici la fin de cette année
scolaire
sur l'ensemble de ses activités
l'association soutien jusqu'à 400
familles depuis le début du
déconfinement le 11 mai les forêts
yvelinois sont de nouveau accessibles
aux promeneurs et elles ont été prises
d'assaut depuis pour des balades dans
cet habitat naturel des animaux sauvages
qui s'étaient habitués peut-être à une
certaine quiétude bon sens michel béal
vous êtes le directeur de l'agencé
territoriale ile de france ouest de
lodève le nfc bien sûr la l'office
national des forêts déjà est ce que
cette réouverture des forêts une bonne
nouvelle que les yvelinois les
franciliens se réapproprie à nouveau cet
espace c'est bien sûr une bonne nouvelle
pour les habitants et qui ont été
confinés qui sont restés de longues
semaines à la maison et aujourd'hui on
voit bien de par la fréquentation des
forêts depuis depuis quelques semaines
qu'ils avaient besoin de ça qu'ils
viennent nombreux très très très
nombreux même de mémoire de forestiers
en ap et pas vu autant de monde en forêt
en forêt dans les yvelines en forêt de
saint germain pour écrabouiller ou dans
les forêts très proche de paris ça
s'explique aussi parce que il ya encore
la semaine dernière ou l'avant
seuls les forêts étaient ouvertes les
parcs et jardins étaient encore fermés
et donc partie jardin nous ont ouvert
que depuis le week-end de pentecôte
donc les forêts ont beaucoup de
visiteurs et justement avec cette grande
présence humaine en forêt comment les
animaux sauvages ont-ils vécu ce ce
déconfinement eux qui s'étaient habitués
peut-être une certaine tranquillité
absolue maintenant il s'était notamment
les animaux on connaît qu'on voit le
plus souvent comme les oiseaux comme les
mammifères et dans nos forêts il ya des
cerfs et chevreuils des s'impliquer et
ont également beaucoup évidemment
d'oiseaux d'oiseaux sauvages et bien ces
animaux-là avait pris l'habit
l'udps le thé le 15 mars dès le 17 mars
ne plus avoir beaucoup de monde voire
pas du tout et donc qu'ils étaient moins
farouches ils étaient moins de remous un
furtif et donc pour nous forestier qui
auront pu continuer d'exercer nos
missions et nos métiers
même avec le sentiment on pouvait voir
beaucoup plus facilement des animaux en
forêt de versailles en forêt de meudon
en forêt de rambouillet parce que ils
étaient au moins apeuré il ya un an il
était moins par le public
les promeneurs ou même par les usagers
de la route de ce qu'il y avait aussi
moins de circulation dans les eaux qui
traverse les forêts sont les voyait
davantage à proximité des routes c'est
ça c'est ces animaux si oui aussi et
donc on a pu s'apercevoir par exemple
que des oiseaux pourtant des foires rare
avait puni chez en bordure de chemin
on a vu des pics des pics épeiches des
piques par avoir investi des arbres des
qualités puisqu'il y jetant des qualités
dans les arbres bon au creux et qu'il
était des fois tout près d'un chemin
forestier alors qu'ils ne l'auraient pas
fait l'année d'avant parce que c'est un
chemin était très fréquentée par des
piétons
donc c'est les importants camps puissent
faire passer ce message
le public est vraiment très nombreux
donc faites attention c'est une période
de fragilité pour la nature c'est
l'époque des mises bas il ya des jeunes
des jeunes des jeunes chevreuil par
exemple et donc c'est obligatoire
d'avoir franchir laisse jusqu'au 30 juin
ccc réglementaires pour que les animaux
même si c'est des chien d'appartement et
ils ont quand même ça craint
il faut pas qu'ils dérangent les animaux
et pareil pour les niches et les oiseaux
qu'on peut voir on peut entendre des
fois d'ailleurs il faut pas s'en
approcher
évitez de d'aller dans les sous bois on
conseille de rester sur les chemins et
surtout et de continuer d'avoir le geste
citoyen de ramener ces déchets on a
énormément de déchets depuis quelques
jours le week-end dernier le week-end de
pentecôte
porter beaucoup des chefs par les
promeneurs on trouve des masques sommes
malheureusement artères confort et c'est
scandaleux et donc on demande vraiment à
ce que les habitants qui ont bénéficié
maintenant de cette forêt puisse aussi
être précautionneux vigilant et ramène
tous leurs déchets leur mythique
détritus non voilà pour ces conseils
c'est à dire si on dresse un premier
bilan de ce déconfinement du retour des
événements en forêt il ya quelques
aspects négatifs vous le disiez
notamment la recrudescence des déchets
qui sont qui sont trouvés en forêt voilà
évidemment on le savait on comprend le
besoin de nature c'est un besoin
physique de faire un peu de marche de
sport mais c'est aussi un besoin
physique c'est à dire de pouvoir
ce petit chic de bois s'aérer s'aérer
l'esprit aussi mais voilà ce qu'on
demande c'est que il faut c'est une
nature c'est une telle diversité fragile
faisons en sorte aussi de la protégée de
la préserver et pan ne pas déranger les
animaux de ramener ces déchets on n'est
pas dans ce parc urbain on n'est pas en
ville il n'y a pas de corbeil
il faut avoir le geste citoyen de
reprendre un petit sac et de ramener ses
déchets à la bise et une dernière
question concernant le élèves comment
c'était justement à adapter à cette
situation vous le disais tout à l'heure
vous avez pu davantage observées dans
meilleures conditions les animaux est ce
que vos activités vos missions ont été
impactés pendant pendant cette période
oui il ya eu un impact évidemment comme
comme tout le monde parce qu'on n'y
était pas préparée donc les les premiers
jours les premières semaines n'ont pu
être confirmées que les activités
individuelles
le métier de forestier terrain c'est un
métier aussi seul ou en travail mais
seul en forêt donc ça s'était toujours
possible et on a pu continuer mais une
partie de nos activités jeux je fais et
atteindre 3 à 4 à 5 personnes ensemble
et bien sûr là il s'est passé un mois et
ce n'est que vers
le 15 avril que les activités
collectives les activités coordonnées
ont pu reprendre et c'est vrai que les
forestiers notamment ceux qui
travaillaient en forêt et travailler
seuls ont pu voir la forêt d'arles et
les deux mois sous un oeil
nous allons tout à fait nouveaux inédits
dîner d'hier on avait notamment dans les
yvelines jamais vu évidemment les forêts
comme ça parce que les forêts ont
toujours parcourue par de nombreuses
personnes
et si on remonte à plusieurs décennies
et par exemple au début du 20e siècle
c'était aussi des charbonniers qui
vivent près des bûcherons qui vivent
leur vie est faite de tout temps la
forêt a été très occupé merci michel
vial d'avoir été avec nous merci
renversé avant merci et je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de l'agencé
territoriale ile de france ouest de
l'eau nf l'office national des forêts
effets du printemps et de nombreuses
journées ensoleillées les allergies aux
pollens ont fait leur retour et sont
particulièrement intense en ce moment
elle les yvelines sont même en rouge sur
la dernière carte du réseau national de
surveillance aérobiologique
c'est à dire on risque très élevé
concentration importante du pollen qui
peut causer l'apparition de symptômes
pour la première fois n'ait boucher
éternuements sécrétions haut niveau et
des yeux et du nez il est conseillé de
se faire traiter en cas de grosse
allergies de se rincer régulièrement et
les yeux et le nez
enfin le port du masque qui est
d'ailleurs fortement recommandée
actuellement dans l'espace public peut
aussi l limiter la diffusion des pollens
durant le confinement il a assuré
uniquement le traitement des affaires
urgentes depuis le 11 mai le tribunal
judiciaire de versailles a repris
l'ensemble de son activité et les
acteurs du monde de la justice ont dû
s'adapter par rapport aux règles
sanitaires comment l'instance est elle
organisée
éléments de réponse avec nicolas landry
port du masque obligatoire gels hydro
alcooliques ou signalétique dans
l'ensemble du bâtiment
le tribunal judiciaire de versailles a
adopté des règles
le sanitaire le déconfinement synonyme
de reprise de l'ensemble des activités
juridictionnelles avec des adaptations
c'est le cas des affaires familiales
habituellement traitée dans un bureau
comme celui ci là il a fallu tout
réorganiser puisque ces audiences là ne
pouvait pas se tenir dans les cabinets
donc on a dû redistribuer tous les
locaux suffisamment vaste de la
juridiction pour que chacun puisse tenir
son activité face aux nombreuses
affaires à traiter certains dossiers
sont déposés au tribunal pour accélérer
le traitement sans passer par une
audience une procédure possible quand
les partis sont représentés par des
avocats lors d'une audience le public
n'est pas acceptée seules les personnes
convoquées sont présentes magistrats
greffiers ministère public ou avocat les
gestes barrières sont respectées entre
chaque personne du côté des affaires
pénales la fin du confinement a entraîné
une recrudescence d'activité il y à la
fois bleus les infractions commises en
flagrant délit donc plus de liberté
permet plus d'action si je puis dire
donc il ya ce qui se passe en temps réel
et puis ya aussi un phénomène de rétro
planning je dirais c'est toutes les
affaires qui étaient programmés avant le
confinement et qui ont été suspendues et
pour lesquels les services d' enquête
police et gendarmerie maintenant peuvent
actionner convoquer les gens et procédé
aux actes et ainsi terminer des affaires
donc c'est affaire arrive évidemment au
parquet et éventuellement devant le
tribunal affaires civiles pénales
familiales ou encore l'application des
peines entre 150 et 200 personnes
fréquentent en moyenne chaque jour le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
environ 300 fonctionnaires et une
centaine de magistrats travaillent sur
place informations pratiques saint
quentin en yvelines a mis en place un
service d' alerte par sms sur simple
inscription les habitants de
l'agglomération pourront recevoir des
informations de vigilance pour le
territoire crise sanitaire catastrophes
naturelles et environnementales
avis de tempête ou encore prévision de
grève l'inscription se fait directement
en ligne
saint quentin en yvelines assure dans un
communiqué que les données collectées
seront utilisés aux seules fins
d'information de l'usager c'est une
tendance du moment peut être amené à se
confirmer avec le confinement les
yvelinois se sont tourné davantage vers
leurs commerces de proximité et aussi
vers des produits
plus locaux c'est le cas par exemple de
la viande marylène iapichino est allé à
la rencontre d'un boucher d'un éleveur
qui ont constaté une forte augmentation
de leur activité regarder la tirelire a
le sourire
et pour cause cette boucherie restée
ouverte durant tout le confinement a
fait le plein on a progressé + plus de
100 % sur le mois d'avril mois de mai
plus de 100 % sans problème j'étais
obligé de créer des emplois j'ai
embauché une caissière
d'après une société d'intérim pour nous
aider port du masque obligatoire
solutions hydro alcooliques à
disposition et sens de circulation
un protocole sanitaire pour rassurer les
clients qui viennent aussi pour la
qualité de la viande française fut très
réticent sur la production industrielle
donc c'est pour ça que je préfère venir
la boucherie de mon quartier la hausse
de la consommation locale cet éleveur
d'auffargis la constate aussi sa
spécificité
les races anciennes est moins présente
sur le marché pour une diversité des
viandes
le tout dans un souci de bien-être des
animaux la demande est complètement
exponentielle en fait aujourd'hui on
refuse à peu près dix ou vingt fois
par rapport à notre production on
pourrait vendre oui au moins 20 fois
plus et on n'aura pas assez de naissance
pour compenser tout cela donc
aujourd'hui je suis obligée de me
retourner vers des voisins agriculteurs
qui ont eu beaucoup de naissances pour
racheter les veaux au sevrage en tout
cas aujourd'hui être présent sur le
circuit des acheteurs en plus de cette
hausse de la demande
la ferme de la petite aurait dû
s'occuper de beaucoup de naissances des
prêts confiné mais pas reposer d'après
une étude opinionway sept français sur
dix estiment que cette crise sanitaire
est l'illustration qu'il faut changer
nos modes de consommation pour des
produits plus responsable c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
demain vendredi vous avez rendez vous
avec marylène iapichino pour le 7-8
l'hebdo c'est un condensé de l'actualité
yvelinoise de la semaine
quant à nous on se retrouve dès lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]